You can't say C++ needs to add anything because C++ already has everything. But it gives you access to all sorts of algorithms, right? You can do a binary search to find that stuff. You can do a hash table lookup to find that stuff. You can do a quadratic lookup on that stuff. There's all sorts of ways of finding that data. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 196, recorded on August 21st, 2024. My name is Connor, and today I interview Aaron Hsu on-site at the Eagle Pub on the campus of the University of Cambridge. We chat about algorithms in APL as
你不能说C++需要添加什么，因为C++已经拥有一切了。但它为你提供了各种算法的访问权限，对吧？你可以用二分查找来寻找那些东西。你可以用哈希表查找来寻找那些东西。你可以在那些东西上进行二次查找。寻找这些数据的方法有很多种。欢迎收听ADSP播客第196期，录制于2024年8月21日。我是Connor，今天我在剑桥大学校园内的Eagle酒吧现场采访Aaron Hsu。我们聊了APL中的算法以及它们的实现。好的。这太史诗了。我们现在在历史悠久的Eagle酒吧，感谢Ben Dean和Tristan Brindle这两位ADSP的前嘉宾的推荐。我和Aaron Hsu在一起，他是ADSP的首次嘉宾。我相信你是第18期的嘉宾。我其实不知道你在ArrayCast上是第几位嘉宾。所以我们会把链接放在节目说明的顶部，供那些听完这次对话后还想了解更多Aaron Hsu信息的听众参考。在我做一个简短的介绍后，我会让你自我介绍，你最出名的是
well as their implementations. All right. This is pretty epic. We are here in the historic Eagle Pub, thanks to the recommendation of both Ben Dean and Tristan Brindle to previous guests on ADSP. And I'm here with Aaron Hsu, first-time guest on ADSP. I believe you were episode 18. I don't actually know what number guest you were on ArrayCast. So we will link at the top of the show notes for folks that can't get enough of Aaron Hsu after this conversation. I'll let you introduce yourself after a brief introduction from me, most famous for being
作为CodeDefunds编译器的作者和创造者，这是一个既在GPU上运行，我相信也是在GPU上编译的APL。它被设计为在GPU上自托管。这在许多可以编译的语言中是无法做到的，既在GPU上运行又在GPU上编译。是的，没错。设计为自托管是核心理念。你在Dialog Limited工作。
the author, creator of the CodeDefunds compiler, which is a APL that is both run on the GPU and is, I believe, compiled on the GPU. It's designed to host itself on the GPU. Which can't be said about many languages that can be compiled, both run and compiled on the GPU. Yeah, nope. Designed to self-host itself is the idea. And you work at Dialog Limited.
我想你过去几年，基本上是从你的论文或完成博士学位以来就在那里工作。他们资助了编译器研究。是的。我不确定，你还有什么要补充的吗？你是一个有强烈观点、坚持己见且有很多爱好和激情的人。我们刚才讨论过，我们俩拥有的与其说是激情，不如说是痴迷，你知道的。它们并没有太多的重叠。
You have for, I think, the last few years since basically your dissertation or completing your PhD. They fund the compiler research. Yes. And I'm not sure, do you want to add anything? You're a man with strong opinions, strongly held of many hobbies and passions. We were just discussing that it's not so much passions that both of us have, but obsessions, you know. They don't overlap a lot.
我喜欢深入研究，如果有人能提供超过我所做研究和证据的证据，我很快就会改变观点。问题在于，伙计们，他自己已经做了大量的研究。所以你必须提供的证据量并不小。我们，我想我也应该提到，对于那些不知道Eagle酒吧在哪里以及它为什么具有历史意义的人，我们是在剑桥，剑桥大学校园。我相信，DNA就是在这里。我想标牌上是这么写的。
I like to do a deep dive, and I'm quick to change an opinion provided that you provide evidence that exceeds the evidence and research that I've done. The problem there, folks, is that he has done an immense amount of research himself. So the amount that you have to provide is not trivial. What are the things that we, and so I guess I should also mention, for those that don't know where the Eagle Pub is and why it's historic, we are on the Cambridge, University of Cambridge campus. This is where, I believe, DNA. I think that's what the sign says.
标牌上就是这么写的。它会出现在节目说明中。但对我来说更有趣的是，这是一间艾伦·图灵（计算机之父）经常光顾的酒吧，因为他曾就读于剑桥大学下属的国王学院。我们坐的这张桌子，可能就是图灵先生本人坐过的。这是有可能的。
That's what the sign said. It'll be in the show notes. But also, more interesting to me, this is a pub that Alan Turing, the father of computing, frequented as he went to King's College, one of the colleges associated with the University of Cambridge. Potentially, we're sitting at a table that Mr. Turing himself sat at. It's possible.
这是有可能的。我的意思是，那已经是半个多世纪前的事了。占据了大致相同的空间几何位置。是的。如果不是同一张桌子，你知道，至少我们经常光顾他过去几十年经常光顾的地方。我们现在在Iverson学院。可能没有听这个播客的人不知道Arraycast是什么。这是一个为期一周的聚会。
It's possible. I mean, it was over half a century ago. Inhabiting the overall same spatial geometry. Yeah. If it wasn't the same table, you know, at least we are frequenting the space that he frequented in decades past. We are here at Iverson College. Probably no one that's listening to this podcast that doesn't listen to Arraycast as well knows what that is. It's a week-long get-together.
你自己之前应该参加过几次吧。我想之前参加过两次，是的。所以这是你的第三次。这是一个大约25到30人的集合。我不确定过去几年是多少人。大约就是这样，是的。差不多。20到30人，我认为是一个相当典型的数字。
You yourself have been to, I think, a couple before. I think two before, yeah. So this is your third one. And it's a collection of about 25, 30 folks. I'm not sure how many it was in years past. It's about that, yeah. About the same. 20 to 30 is, I think, a pretty typical number.
还有一些这次没参加但过去参加过的人，比如K和Shakti背后的臭名昭著的Arthur Whitney。还有谁参加过？我想Roger Hui参加过，他是J语言的主要实现者，对于那些听说过它的人来说。所以这是一个，你会怎么说，志同道合的人聚集在一起分享想法，同时他们也在进行各自的个人工作。我想，我听说过它被称为，不是这个
And some other folks not attending this time, but have attended in the past, the infamous Arthur Whitney behind the Ks and Shakti. Who else has attended that? Roger Hui, I think, attended, who is the main implementer of the J language, for those that have heard of that. So it's a, what would you say, a congregating of like-minded folks to share ideas while they're still working on their own personal work. And I think it's, I've heard it referred to as like an, not this
具体来说，但这种会议被称为非会议（unconference）。这是一个没有日程安排的会议。我认为这符合经典学术学院的传统，即志同道合的人聚在一起追求思想和知识的进步，分享经验等等。我认为这在总体上就是它的吸引力所在。这一届与往年相比如何？因为我想上一次是在疫情之前，所以已经过去几年了。毫无疑问，人群更年轻了，但也更加折衷。所以与过去的学院相比，背景非常非常多，过去的学院通常在数组编程领域有更强大、更密集的资深人士代表，而现在的学院拥有更广泛的人选，他们在数组编程领域有很大的热情和不同程度的经验。
specifically, but this kind of meeting as like an unconference. It's a conference without a schedule. I think it's in the tradition of classic scholastic colleges of a meeting of shared minds to pursue the furtherment of ideas and knowledge and share experiences and things like that. I think that's sort of the appeal in general. How is this addition compared to years past? Because I think the last one was before the pandemic, so it's been a few years. So without a doubt, the crowd is younger, but also way more eclectic. So there are many, many different backgrounds compared to in past colleges, where the past colleges had usually a stronger, more intense representation of senior people in the array programming field, whereas this college now has a much broader selection of people who have a lot of passion and varying degrees of experience in the array programming field.
这改变了氛围或正在进行的对话吗？有时。有时。有时？是的。我想我们做的一件事是，我认为我们现在在可以涵盖的主题上更加活跃和广泛。你知道，我们有很多新的东西在被讨论
Has that changed the vibe or the conversations that have been happening? Sometimes. Sometimes. happening? Sometimes. Sometimes. Sometimes? Yeah. I'd say one thing we do is we can, I think we are a lot more active and broad in our topics that we can cover right now. You know, we have a lot more new things that are being discussed
而不是像我们大家都非常熟悉的那些东西的精确改进。是的。是的。所以有很多新的想法在播种，可以去尝试。是的，我想可能在往年，你不会有与会者创造出全新的、从未听说过的数组语言。席卷全国的全新语言。是的，是的。
instead of like really precise refinements on things that we all know quite well. Yes. Yeah. So there's a lot of new seeding of ideas to play with. Yeah, I think probably in years past, you didn't have creators of brand new, never heard about before array languages by some of the attendees. Brand new languages sweeping the nation. Yeah, yeah.
我们指的是Kai Schmidt创造的Wiwa语言。他在这里。他周一做了一个演讲。我想有很多，我不会说下巴掉下来，但绝对是……钦佩。是的，皱起的眉头和在该语言中做出的一些有趣的设计决定。但那是另一天的话题了。
We're referring to the Wiwa language created by Kai Schmidt. He's here. He gave a presentation on Monday. I think there was a lot of, I won't say dropped jaws, but definitely... Admiration. Yeah, burrowed frowns and some interesting design decisions made in that language. But that is a topic for another day.
我可能想提的一件事是，鉴于这不一定是一个数组社区，数组社区之外的其他人可能知道我过去作为Scheme开发者的背景。我是R6RS、R7RS Scheme标准标准化小型工作组的成员之一。所以就铺垫一些更多的历史而言。如果他们不知道数组语言，他们可能知道LISP。他们可能知道Scheme或LISP之类的东西。
Something I might want to mention, given that this is not necessarily an array community, other people outside of the array community might know my background as a scheme developer back in the day. And I was one of the members of the small working group for the standardization of the R6RS, R7RS scheme standards. So as far as laying out some more history. If they don't know array languages, they might know LISPs. They might know scheme know LISPs. They might know Scheme or LISPs or something like that.
是的，我的意思是，C++标准模板库和算法之父Alex Stepanov，众所周知也是一位Scheme开发者，我想，我不知道是不是十年，但他对一些想法进行了探索，他在几种不同的语言中探索过。Java是一种，Ada是另一种，我想他也有Scheme。实际上，他有关于编程的笔记，那是一份88页的文档，他第一次实现归约（reduction）
Yeah, that is, I mean, Alex Stepanov, the father of the standard template library and algorithms in C++, was famously also a Scheme developer for, I think, like, I don't know if it was a decade, but he had some exploration of ideas that he explored in a couple different languages. Java was one of them, Ada was another, and I think he had a scheme as well. And actually, he had like notes on programming, which was like an 88-page document, where his first implementation of a reduction
是在Scheme中，但他有一个小注释说，reduce取自APL。所以APL和C++之间实际上有一条非常微弱的虚线。内积（Interproduct）、IOTA，我想相邻差（adjacent difference）甚至也是取自，名字取自APL中某种NY的归约。所以是一条非常微弱的线，但IOTA绝对是。
was in scheme, but he had a little comment that said, reduce is taken from APL. And so there's actually a kind of a very faint dotted line between APL and C++. Interproduct, IOTA, I think adjacent difference even was taken from, the name was taken from the kind of NY's reduction in APL. So a very faint line, but IOTA definitely.
IOTA 100%。来自APL。0和1布尔值也来自APL。那是C++里的吗？哦，我猜是隐式转换。是的，隐式转换。是的。
IOTA 100%. Comes from APL. And 0 and 1 Booleans also come from APL. Is that in C++, though? Oh, I guess the implicit conversions. Yeah, implicit conversions over. Yes.
有很多语言，令许多人懊恼的是，它们都有这个特性。但这可是高德纳（Knuth）最喜欢的APL特性。真的吗？是的。他在他的《计算机程序设计艺术》中写到了它，这是他最喜欢的。他称它们为Iverson布尔值之类的。真的吗？它取自APL，他喜欢经常使用它们。
There's many languages to many people's chagrin that have that. But it was famously Knuth's favorite feature from APL. Really? Yeah. He writes about it in his Art of Computer Programming, his favorite. He calls them the Iverson Booleans or something like that. Really? And it was taken from APL, and he likes to use them a lot.
这是我在APL中偶尔会认为理所当然的事情之一。很多时候我忘记了秩多态性（rank polymorphism）和作为0和1的布尔值（整数空间的一个子集）的重要性，因为它导致了，比如，你可以扩展布尔运算以在很多时候作用于整个整数范围，我相信APL就是这样做的，比如在你拥有与（and）和或（or）的情况下。扩展整数是LCM和GCD。它也以容差形式扩展到了浮点数。
It's one of the things that I, at times, take for granted in APL. A lot of times I forget about the importance of rank polymorphism and Booleans as 0 and 1, a subset of the integer space, because it leads to, like, you can extend Boolean operations to work on the full integer range a lot of times, which I believe APL does that, like, in the case where you have and and or. The extended integers is LCM and GCD. And it is also extended in a tolerant form to floating points as well.
我曾做过噩梦，试图确保其兼容的实现，但是的。你是说那些原语有针对浮点数的GCD实现？是的。怎么做？什么？是的。是的，它是，你必须，你必须做。它是完全不同的算法吗？它是相同的，它是相同的基本算法。你做中国剩余定理类型的东西。
I have had nightmares trying to ensure compatible implementations of that, but yes. You're telling me that there's a GCD implementation of those primitives for floating points? Yep. How? What? Yes. Yes, it's, you have to, you have to do. Is it a different algorithm entirely? It's the same, it's the same basic algorithm. You do the Chinese remainder theorem type stuff.
它是相同的基本GCD类型的东西，但你必须，你必须，对浮点数进行某种因式分解以标准化它们，或者你必须做一些事情，使其进入某种标准形式，然后你才能得到结果。我想一定有某种离散化。否则，你可能会有无限数量的答案，不是吗？所以这就是四元数CT（容差比较）发挥作用的地方。所以通常情况下，对于大多数情况，如果你想在这个问题上得到一个有用的结果，你会比较一个范围内的等价性，而不是浮点数上的精确位级相等。所以你必须进行软相等检查。然后你像通常那样执行算法，它遵循相同的基本数学结果，简单的那些，
It's the same basic GCD type things, but you have to, you have to, there's some kind of factorization on the floats to normalize them or something that you have to do that gets into some kind of standard form that you then can get a result. I would think there has to be some kind of discretization. Otherwise, you could have an infinite number of answers, no? So that's where quad CT, tolerant comparison, comes in. So normally, for most cases, if you want a useful result on this, you compare for equivalency across a range, not on exact bitwise equality over floats. So you have to do a soft equality checking. And then you execute the algorithm as you typically would, and it follows the same basic mathematical results, the simple ones,
你只是把它应用到浮点数上。这是一个有争议的特性。是的，有趣。我这辈子从来没考虑过浮点数上的GCD。很多人也没考虑过。好吧，也许我们应该保持在，你称它们为什么，花哨的？也许是深奥的算法，既然这是ADSP算法。ADSP代表什么？
and you just apply it to floats. It's a contentious feature. Yeah, interesting. I've never even in my life considered GCD on floating point. Neither have many other people. Well, maybe we should stay on the topic of, what do you call them, fancy? Maybe esoteric algorithms, seeing as this is the ADSP algorithms. What does ADSP stand for?
它是取自尼古拉斯·沃思（Nicholas Wirth）那本书的缩写，《算法+数据结构=程序》。当然，当然。有一次在某一集里，有人提到，哦，像ADSP，这是一本书。我说，不，这是一个播客。然后他们说，不，就像，你从书里取的名字。
It's the acronym taken from the Nicholas Wirth book, Algorithms plus Data Structures equals Programs. Of course, of course. One time on an episode, someone mentioned, oh, like ADSP, it's a book. And I was like, no, it's a podcast. And then they were like, no, like, you took your name from the book.
我说，哦，是的，我是怎么取的？那已经是160集之后了。我已经忘记我们从哪里偷来的名字了。你已经失去了你的根。你不再有联系了。这是这个播客新2.0版本的一部分，我们正试图带回更多的算法和数据结构对话。所以也许我们现在先录制。
And I was like, oh, yeah, how did I? It was like 160 episodes in. I'd forgotten where we stole the name from. You've lost your roots. You're no longer connected. It is a part of the new 2.0 version of this podcast that we're trying to bring back more algorithms and data structures conversation. So maybe we'll record for now.
我们有一个主题，但也许我们把它留到这次对话的最后30分钟。让我们谈谈算法。那么还有哪些算法，要么是你真正喜欢的存在于APL中并且你一直依赖的，或者也许保持在这个花哨的空间里，我永远不会猜到GCD在浮点数上有效？还有其他一些不太有用或实际上有用的深奥东西，你可以在APL中触及，而你没有，C++应该考虑添加到它的算法头文件中吗？
We have a topic lined up, but maybe we'll save that for the last 30 minutes of this conversation. Let's talk about algorithms. So what are more algorithms, either that you really like that exists in APL that you rely on all the time, or maybe staying in this fancy space that I would have never guessed that GCD works on floating point? Are there other sort of esoteric things that are less useful or actually useful that you can reach for in APL that you don't have, that C++ should consider adding to its algorithm header?
你知道，我认为你不能说C++需要添加任何东西，因为C++已经拥有一切了。所以，就像，你不能……还没有。我们没有反射。我不知道。如果我知道一些C++程序，有人在他们自己的可执行文件上做二进制反射并获取数据。就像，你可以做到。
You know, I think you can't say C++ needs to add anything, because C++ already has everything. And so, like, you can't... Not yet. We don't have reflection. I don't know. If I know some C++ programs, somebody's doing binary reflection on their own executables and getting data out. Like, you can do it.
你只需要疯狂一点。你可以做任何事。那是真的。它还不是一个语言特性。当你使用这些语言时，语言特性和某种黑客在位级别上做某事之间的区别，变得非常薄，你知道吗？你知道，C指令和带有内在函数的汇编内联块之间有什么区别？你知道吗？我不知道。
You just have to be crazy. You can do anything. That's true. It's not a language feature yet. When you work in these languages, the difference between a language feature and just some kind of hacker doing something on the bit level is, it gets pretty thin, you know? You know, what's the difference between a C instruction and an assembly inline block with intrinsics? You know? I don't know.
所以，至于算法，我想我实际上倾向于通过稍微提高你的基础抽象层来避免过多地考虑算法，
So but as far as algorithms, I think I actually I tend to have grown into preferring to avoid having to think about algorithms too much by shifting the abstraction just a little bit up at your base
从而更多地担心整体的参与类型。所以也许稍微高一点的层次，你指定，我想做一些属于算法家族的事情，然后允许你的实现从中选择最好的算法。这可能会让你在不必像可用性案例那样意识到所有不同种类的算法的情况下，获得更多的算法访问权限，我有点喜欢那样，但在通用计算领域，C++我认为比其他人罪过少，但仍然有罪，我认为不需要指针追踪的替代算法，有很多方法可以处理扁平数据、编码数据，你知道，在稍微丰富的数学领域（如线性代数或矩阵或数值空间）中的表示。
layer to worrying more about the overall type of engagement. So maybe a little bit up at your base layer to worrying more about the overall type of engagement. So maybe a little bit higher level where you're specifying, I want to do something that's within a family of algorithms, and then allowing your implementation of that to select the best algorithm out of that. And that may be giving you more access to algorithms without having to be as aware of all the different varieties of algorithms that are out there as a usability case i kind of like that but but within the general computing sphere c++ i think is less guilty of this than others but still guilty i think alternative algorithms that do not require pointer chasing that would be there are many ways in which you can work with flat data, encoded data, you know, representations in a slightly richer mathematical domain like linear algebra or matrices or numerical spaces.
在那个空间里，而不是仅仅构建一组作用于指针的抽象数据类型，我会鼓励人们尝试不要把指针作为连接数据的核心方式。嗯，有趣的是在C++中，存在于你的数据结构和算法之间的迭代器抽象实际上意味着，就像迭代器有一个.next接口，对于某些数据结构，你知道，元素在内存中是连续的，所以没有指针追踪。
Something in that space, instead of just building a set of abstract data types that operate over pointers, I would encourage people to play with not having to go to the pointer as your core way of connecting data together. Well, so interestingly in C++, the iterator abstraction that lives between your data structure and your algorithm actually means that, like an iterator has an interface of the.next, which for certain data structures, you know, the elements live contiguously in memory, so there is no pointer chasing.
所以因为它们中间有一个抽象，如果你使用链表并调用像find之类的算法，或者任何你需要遍历的算法，你将会进行指针追踪，但如果你的底层数据结构是vector或std array，实际上那里没有指针追踪。所以实际上，算法在某种程度上与你是否在进行指针追踪是脱钩的。特别是迭代器模式。是的，所以它实际上是基于你在底层选择的数据结构。在这个意义上，你是说如果你要，我们没有图数据结构。
So because they have an abstraction in between, if you're using a linked list and you invoke some algorithm like find or whatever where you have to traverse, you're going to pointer chase, but if you're underlining data structure as a vector or a std array, there's actually no pointer chasing there. So really, the algorithm is in a way divorced from whether or not you are doing pointer chasing. Especially with the iterator patterns. Yeah, so it's really based on the data structure that you're choosing underneath. Which, in this sense, you're saying if you were going to, we don't have a graph data structure.
但如果我们有，你会主张表示你想要连续的扁平表示，内部表示，你的复杂结构的实现，尽量避免到处都是指针，你知道，那将是我的首选，你知道，我的意思是C++总的来说我们做得很好，因为就像你对此相当擅长，就像C++在所有人中并不差，是的，vector是我们的首选，甚至一些容器实际上不是容器，它们是容器适配器，比如stack、queue和deque都只是vector之上的包装器，所以你可以把它们实现为链表，但我们避免这样做，因为缓存局部性和指针追踪很重要。关于C++有很多话可以说，但是，你知道，
But if we did have one, you would be advocating for representing that you want contiguous flat representations internal representations implementations of your of your complex structures try to avoid having pointers all over the place you know that's that would be my first preference you know i mean c++ in general we do that quite well because like you're pretty good about it like c++ amongst everybody is not bad yeah the vector is our go-to and even some of the containers are not actually containers they're container adapters like the the stack and the queue and the deck are all just wrappers on top of vector and and so like you could implement those as linked lists but we avoid that because cache locality and portrait chasing is important. There's a lot of things that can be said about C++ but, you know,
C++中有一种性能文化，所以这些事情确实很重要。例如，我认为最近在更广泛的编程时代精神中出现的一件事是，作为管理数据的一种机制，使用更大的对象池，而不是RAII或其他类似的东西。我认为现代C++倾向于向初学者推销很多东西，这种带有特定容器和单对象关注点的RAII现代C++。我认为有一个额外的层次，我同意一些人的观点，学习如何在顶层考虑对象池，而不是在你的空间中间分配这些带有智能指针的东西来管理你的生命周期。
there is a culture of performance in C++ so these things do matter. For instance, I think something that's come up in the broader programming zeitgeist recently is the idea of larger object
类似这样的东西，我认为是在游戏编程世界之外被低估的技术。而且C++真的很擅长这个。我认为如果你不利用这一点，如果你要强迫自己使用像C++这样的语言，你就是在浪费很多东西。你在你的CodeDefense编译器中使用过这些技术吗？是的。真的吗？所以你是自己手动实现的吗？所以我的一个有趣的失败是，我有一个引用计数的内存管理系统，它基于栈生命周期进行分配和释放，非常接近你认为的C++中的智能指针，
pools as a mechanism for managing your data as opposed to RAII or other things like that. And I think modern C++ tends to do a lot of selling to beginning C++ programmers, this modern C++ of RAII with these particular containers and single object focuses on things like that. And I think there's an extra level that I agree with some people on learning how to think maybe in terms of object pools at a top level instead of allocating these with smart pointers in the middle of your space for managing your lifetimes.
与共享指针相同的基本概念。而且，你知道，那有一些开销。所以我心想，你知道吗，我要做一些对象池，你知道，我自己管理这些内存。我要，你知道，使用我自己的分配器而不是做malloc。我说，好吧，你知道吗，我要做它。它将有点像基于栈的分配器，有点像Linux内核中的slab分配器等等。所以我实现了所有这些，出来后，运行得非常漂亮，性能与我没做时完全一样，然后我开始思考，我想，好吧，你知道吗，那个
Stuff like that, I think, is an underappreciated technique outside of, say, the game programming world. And C++ is really good at it. And I think you're kind of leaving a lot on the table if you don't take advantage of that, if you're going to force yourself to use a language like C++. Have you used these techniques in your CodeDefense compiler? Yes. Really? And so are you manually implementing that yourself? So one of my interesting failures was that I had a ref counted memory management system that allocated and deallocated based on stack lifetimes, very close to what you would think of as like smart pointers in C++,
有点愚蠢，因为底层操作系统基本上就是在做我刚刚重新实现的事情，所以我只是为自己重新实现了一个内核malloc，并且得到了完全相同的性能。我扔掉了它，我扔掉了它。我在那项工作上提交了大约10次，然后你会看到所有这些代码的巨大回滚。我只是，你知道，再见。我不再需要那个了。所以我做其他事情。但以一种避免在整个程序中管理引用计数的方式管理这些对象的原则，
the same basic concept as a shared pointer. And, you know, that had some overhead. So I thought, you know what, I'm going to do some object pooling, you know, manage this memory myself. I'm going to, you know, use my own allocator instead of doing a malloc. And I said, all right, you know what, I'm going to do it. It's going to be sort of like a bump stack allocator based a little bit like the slab allocator in Linux's kernel and all that stuff. And so I implemented all that, came out, worked beautifully and ran exactly the same performance wise as when i didn't and then i got to thinking i was like well you know what that
所以基本上比仅仅智能指针走得更远，摆脱程序中的智能指针，并在更高级别拥有对象池，这样你就不用一直上下调整引用计数之类的东西了。你知道，那是一个大的，那是我会考虑的事情。是的，有一些，我不确定是不是现代C++指南，但有一些指南我认为把智能指针仅仅视为全局变量。
was kind of stupid because the underlying operating system is basically doing exactly what i just re-implemented and so i had just re-implemented a kernel malloc in for myself and got exactly the same performance i tossed it i tossed it. I got about 10 commits in on that work, and then you'll see a giant revert of all that code. And I just, you know, goodbye. I don't need that anymore. So I do other things. But the principle of managing those objects in a way that avoids needing to manage ref counts throughout your program,
根据你是谁，人们对于它们是好东西还是坏东西有强烈的感受。这算是C++的美妙之处，对吧？就像每个人都可以成为自己的教会。因为你基本上可以挑选任何……实际上，也许这不是美妙之处。也许是C++的诅咒
so basically going even further than just smart pointers, getting rid of smart pointers in your program and having object pools at a higher level so you don't have to bump ref counts up and down all the time and stuff like that. You know, that's a big, that's something I would consider. Yeah, there's some, I'm not sure if it's modern C++ guidelines, but there's a couple guidelines I think that consider smart pointers as just global variables.
是你被降级为只能挑选你喜欢的C++子集，然后总是，你知道。这是我从Facebook的一位经理那里听到的，当他们自己编码时，他们喜欢使用C++，但当他们编码并管理团队时，他们从不使用C++
And depending on who you are, folks have strong feelings on whether or not those are a good thing or a bad thing. It's kind of the beauty of C++, right? It's like each person can be his own church. Because you kind of get to pick whatever... Actually, maybe it's not the beauty. Maybe it's the curse of C++
因为每个人都有他们想要编程的不同风格，试图强制执行一种一致的风格要困难得多。所以他们选择了Rust。你得到了更多的保证。需要的代码审查要少得多。而且你可以直接说，我们正在使用Rust格式。
is that you're relegated to picking only the subset of C++ you like and then always being, you know. This is what I've heard from a manager at Facebook that when they code on their own, they love to use C++, but when they code and are managing a team, they never use C++
它消除了很多如果你在C++代码库中编码时最终会产生的争论。是的，好吧，如果我们想对事情变得刻薄和挑剔，我对Rust和C++有同样的抱怨，那就是语言本身并不鼓励对生态系统的深度、内在记忆。你倾向于
because everyone has a different style that they want to program in and trying to mandate a consistent style is so much harder. And so they choose Rust. You get way more guarantees. There's way less code review needed. And you can just say, we're using Rust format.
做大量的查找，大量的引用，大量的自动补全，其中很多是我需要为这件事调用哪个库，我更喜欢当我能思考一个问题时，把语言放在我的脑子里，而不必去查API参考，不必每小时或每30分钟去查一些东西来做
And it gets rid of a lot of the arguments that you end up having if you're coding in a C++ code base. Yeah, well, if we want to get snarky and critical about things, I have the same complaint about Rust and C++, which is simply that the languages do not encourage deep, inherent memorization of the ecosystem. You tend to
某事。我只是想让所有这些都存在于我的脑子里，我只想编程。我不想处理所有那些其他的东西。好吧，也许这是一个机会。所以关于你脑子里的东西，你提到了算法。你说你更喜欢某种抽象家族。但当涉及到原语时，很多这些映射到我们认为C++中的算法。所以什么是，你知道，你最喜欢的原语，我的意思是，其中一些，就像我说的，存在于C++中的IOTA。这是否真的是一个算法，你知道，它存在于，实际上它存在于数值头文件中，这是一组小的数值算法。Diotic IOTA，虽然。APL中的Diotic IOTA和IOTA下划线，它们对应于一些非常有趣的
be doing a lot of lookups, a lot of references, a lot of autocompletes, a lot of which library do I need to call for this thing, and I much prefer when I can think about a problem, have the language in my head, and not have to go to an API reference, not have to look something up every hour or every 30 minutes to go have to do
案例。Diotic IOTA。引导人们了解什么是，实际上引导人们了解，以防他们碰巧不知道IOTA是什么。所以IOTA是允许你生成数字或生成离散空间，在n维离散空间中的原语。所以在向量的情况下，你将生成自然数。它是向量的索引空间。在矩阵中，你正在生成矩阵的索引空间，这将是像0，
something. I just want all of that sitting in my head, and I just want to program. I don't want to have to deal with all that other stuff. Well, maybe this is an opportunity. So of the stuff sitting in your head, you mentioned algorithms. You said you preferred sort of families of abstractions. But when it comes to primitives, a lot of these map to what we consider algorithms in C++. So what are, you know, your go-to favorite primitives that, I mean, some of them, like I said, IOTA that exists in C++. Whether that's really an algorithm, you know, it lives in the, actually it lives in the numeric header, which are a small set of numeric algorithms. Diotic IOTA, though. Diotic IOTA and IOTA underbar in APL, which those correspond to some really interesting
0，0，1，0，2，1，0，等等，作为某种二维数组的索引。你可以用它达到任意数量的维度，并且你生成了某种存在的整个索引空间。所以C++ iota基本上是APL iota的一维子集。对，对。所以二元（dyadic）iota。二元iota，这是一个很酷的设计问题，对吧？因为二元iota，当你表达你想要什么时，
cases. Diotic IOTA. Walk people through what, and actually walk people in case they happen to not know what IOTA is. So IOTA is the primitive that would allow you to generate the numbers or generate the discrete space in a n-dimensional discrete space. So in the vector case, you would be generating the natural numbers. It's the index space of a vector. In a matrix, you're generating the index space of a matrix, which would be things like 0,
它真的只是，我想在两组事物之间找到匹配的元素，对吧？我有一个事物的一组有序集合，我想在另一个事物的有序集合中找到匹配的事物，对吧？这是一个非常简单的规范，但它为你提供了各种算法的访问权限，对吧？你可以用二分查找来寻找那些东西。
0, 0, 1, 0, 2, 1, 0, et cetera, as indices into a two-dimensional array of some sort. And you can go up to any number of dimensions with that, and you generate sort of the entire index space that exists. So the C++ iota is basically the one-dimensional subset of the APL iota. Right, right, right. And so dyadic iota. And dyadic iota, this is a cool design question you have, right? Because dyadic iota, when you express what you want,
你可以用哈希表查找来寻找那些东西。你可以在那些东西上进行二次查找。在幕后寻找这些数据的方法有很多种，我真的很喜欢不必考虑我想要跳表还是哈希表还是二分查找或其他什么，并允许以后根据你实际拥有的数据来决定，而不是先验地决定我们要把它做成哈希表，因为我们认为这就是我们的数据
it's really just, I want to find matching elements between two sets of things, right? I have an ordered set of one thing, and I want to find the matching things in an ordered set of another thing, right? And that's a really simple specification, but it gives you access to all sorts of algorithms, right? You can do a binary search to find that stuff.
看起来的样子，我们正在说二元（dyadic）这个词，呃，把它转换成，呃，我的意思是我也犯了同样的错误，把它转换成C++术语，那只是意味着一个二元函数。不是位运算，而只是一个接受两个参数的函数，而iota是一个单子或一元函数，接受一个参数。所以对于这个案例，让我们给他们一个简短的例子。如果你有列表2，3和1，2，3，4，5，并且你在那两者之间放置二元iota，因为二元函数或二元函数在APL中是中缀的，那给了你
You can do a hash table lookup to find that stuff. You can do a quadratic lookup on that stuff. There's all sorts of ways of finding that data behind the scenes, and there's something I really like about not having to think whether I want a skip list or a hash table or a binary search or something else and allowing that to be decided on later based on the actual data that you have instead of a priori deciding we're going to make this a hash table because we think this is what our data is
什么结果？它将查看那些作为左参数的元素，那第二个集合，它将尝试在另一个集合中找到匹配的元素，并给你，返回给你指向那个空间或那个集合的索引。所以如果2，3是你的左参数，2，3是你的左参数。然后你说1到5是你的右参数。所以你会得到，嗯，其中一些不匹配。所以有一个额外的边缘情况，它说
going to look like we are saying the word dyadic uh to convert that to uh I mean I made the same mistake to convert that to c++ speak that just means a binary function. Not bitwise arithmetic, but just a function that takes two arguments, whereas iota is a monadic or unary function, takes one argument. So for the case, let's give them a short example. If you've got the lists 2, 3, and 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, and you place dyadic iota in between those two because binary functions or dyadic functions are infix in APL, what does that give
如果你找不到它，只需返回比不匹配项多一个的索引。所以如果你做了2，3，并且你试图通过那个找到1，2，3，4，5之类的东西，2和3
you as a result? It's going to look at those elements that are the left argument, that second set, and it's going to try to find the matching element in the other set and give you, return you the index pointing into that space or into that set. So if two, three is your left argument, two, three is your left argument. And then you said one to five is your right argument. So you would get the, well, some of those don't match. So there's an extra edge case where it says
在那个1，2，3，4，5中将匹配2，3。对。所以你会得到0，因为2是第一个元素。而3是那个集合中的第二个元素。所以你在那里得到1。而其他所有东西都只会给你2，因为它们在那个集合中找不到它。
if you can't find it, just return the index one more than the unmatched. So if you did 2, 3 and you're trying to find 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 or something through that, the 2 and the 3
所以你会得到2，对于1，0，1，2，2，2。所以它基本上返回给你匹配项的索引。对于所有其他不存在的东西，你会得到长度加一。是的，基本上是匹配项的索引，或者比搜索集中最大的有效索引多一个。对。所以凭你的记忆，你知道，一，这是如何实现的，
in that 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 are going to match on the 2, 3. Right. So you'll get 0 for the 2 because that's the first element. And 3 is the second element in that set. So you get 1 there. And everything else is just going to give you 2 because they can't find it in that set.
我甚至不确定你是否能在Dialog APL中说出来，二，它是如何在CodeDefunds（GPU版本）中实现的，因为我肯定它们非常不同。而且有趣的是你可以使用二分查找，因为二分查找
So you'll get 2 for the 1, 0, 1, 2, 2, 2. So it basically returns you the indices of matched items. And for everything else that doesn't exist, you get a length plus one back. Yeah, basically the index of the matching item or one more than the largest index in the largest valid index for the searching set. Right. And so off the top of your head, do you know how, one, this is implemented,
通常不是你在做GPU加速算法时想到的首选算法。对。所以对于像这样的算法，在CPU上，如果你有足够的数据需要做这项工作，建立这些东西的哈希表并查找它是值得的。所以在Dialog解释器中，你实际上通常会为你将要查找的元素集合生成一个哈希表，
and I'm not even sure if you can say in Dialog APL, and two, how it's implemented in CodeDefunds, the GPU version, because I'm sure they're very different. And it's interesting that you could use binary search because binary search
然后你只需查找该集合中的成员资格并找到随之而来的索引。所以键是值，索引是值。问题是我们必须在那里多次使用该值。但问题是构建哈希表有计算成本。所以解释器通常更喜欢在你有一个稳定的数组时这样做。但如果你要搜索的数据量很小，构建哈希表是不值得的。所以解释器通常更喜欢在你有一个稳定的数组时这样做。但如果你要搜索的数据量很小，构建哈希表是不值得的。所以你可以只使用一个，你知道，二次搜索或二分查找
is not typically the top algorithm you think of when you're doing a GPU-accelerated algorithm. Right. So for an algorithm like this, on a CPU, if you have enough data that you need to do this work, it pays to build a hash table of this stuff and look it up. And so in the dialog interpreter, you would, in fact, often generate a hash table for the set of elements you're going to look up,
来在那个空间中找到你的数据。那会有更低的开销。那是更快的路径。而且你可能会在小集合上使用这种模式，而不是在APL中的大集合上，这是非常常见的。在其他语言中，这不像是一个原语。对很多人来说，这算是一个特殊情况。所以他们倾向于不想在同一个原语或同一个库调用中为小情况和大情况进行优化。在CodeDefense编译器中，因为我们关心GPU和CPU，我们的CPU，我们有两个算法，两个空间我们必须实现。CPU情况，我们假设
and then you just look up membership in that set and find the index that goes along with that. So the key is the value, and the index is the value. The problem is that we have to use the value multiple times there. But the problem is there's a computational cost to building the hash table. So very often the interpreter would prefer to do that where you have an array that's stable. But if you have small amounts of data that you're going to search, it's not worth it to build the hash table. So very often, the interpreter will prefer to do that where you have an array that's stable. But if you have small amounts of data that you're going to search, it's not worth it to build the hash table. So you can just use a, you know, a quadratic search or a binary search
它是小的。我们假设它是小的。所以我们使用像二次或二分查找算法在小数组上，因为我们不想要超过1000 1024个。所以我们没有超过2的10次方个这些元素。我们使用非常天真的东西，因为它是低开销的。
to find your data in that space. And that'll have lower overheads. And that's the faster way to go. And it's very common that you might use this pattern on small sets, rather than large sets in APL. In other languages, this isn't as much of a primitive. It's sort of a special case for a lot of people. So they tend not to want to have optimizations for small cases and large cases in the same primitive or same library call. In the CodeDefense compiler, since we care about the GPU and the CPU, our CPU, we have two algorithms, two spaces we have to implement. The CPU case, we're assuming
但在GPU端，我们真的不能做哈希表。就像，做哈希表非常复杂，而且在GPU上做哈希表非常昂贵。你可以做，但我不想维护那种算法。我的意思是，我们做，不是要打断，但我认为在过去的一两年里，我们在不同的库中有很多算法，但我们已经开始在命名空间KUCO中构建
that it's small. We're assuming it's small. So we use like a quadratic or a binary search algorithm on small arrays because we don't want more than like a thousand 1024 of them. So we don't have more than like two to the ten of these elements. We use something very naive because it's low overhead.
对于KU集合，我们有一堆这些不同类型的哈希，因为GPU上不仅仅是一个哈希映射，还有这些静态哈希映射。所以无论如何，如果你在外面想自己动手，如果你不想自己动手，那是非常困难的，有一些哈希映射实现
But on the GPU side, we can't really do a hash table. Like, it's really complex to do a hash table, and it's very expensive to do a hash table on a GPU. You can do it, but I don't want to have to maintain that kind of algorithm. I mean, we do, not to interrupt, but I think it's been in the last one or two years we have a lot of algorithms in different libraries, but we have started building in the namespace KUCO
我们正在推出，问题是，在这个上面工作需要很多工作。所以我所做的是我只使用二分查找，那是非常低的开销。它通常需要对数，对数类型的关键路径。但在实践中，特别是对于那些你想最大化你在这样的问题上实际做的工作量的中间变量，因为在GPU上，
for KU collections we have a bunch of these different types of hash because it's not just one hash map on a GPU there's these static hash maps so anyways if you're thinking out there to roll your own, very difficult if you don't want to roll your own they are some hash map implementations
这可能是一个非常受内存限制的操作。所以当你使用它时，我想尝试最小化它在数据中我们经常使用的中间空间的内存带宽。所以我只使用二分查找，结果证明效果非常好。是的，我正在尝试思考是否有，因为我前几天和Kai聊天，他说他在某些优化中内置了，
that we are rolling out and the problem then is it's a lot of work to work on this. So what I do is I just use the binary search, and that is very low overhead. And it requires logarithmic in general, the logarithmic type critical paths. But in practice, especially for those intermediate variables where you want to maximize the amount of actual work you're doing on a problem like this, because on a GPU,
有点类似于DialogAPL所做的，惯用语识别。他说其中之一是行归约外积，或者他们称之为表。所以你可以建立一个表并对每一行进行归约，那实际上不会具体化。无论如何，我正在尝试思考是否会有某种GPU等价物，可能每个元素的二分查找最终会表现得更好。但你可以做类似的事情。比如融合查找的结果
this might be a very memory-bound sort of operation. And so when you're working with that, I want to try to minimize the memory bandwidth on it for the types of intermediate spaces that we very often would work with in the data. So I just use a binary search, and that turns out to work remarkably well. Yeah, I'm trying to think if there's, because I was chatting with Kai the other day, and he was saying that he has certain optimizations built into,
与下一个操作，是的，就像，我正在尝试思考如果你做了一些外积，你可以从技术上讲用外积来实现二元iota，对于小数组，我确实直接在里面有那个，你可以融合它，是的，而且，这只是针对一般的外积，你是说？是的，是的。好的。外积可以与其他东西融合，因为在GPU上，我们只是把它平铺出来。对。我们进行操作。所以如果你在标量操作上有融合，那么你就可以融合那个外积。
kind of similar to what DialogAPL does, idiom recognition. And he said one of those is a row reduction outer product, or table as they call it. So you can build up a table and do a reduction on each row, and that actually won't materialize. Anyways, I'm trying to think if there would be some GPU equivalent, probably the binary searches for each element would end up being more performant. But you could do something similar. Like fusing the results of the lookup
有点类似于DialogAPL所做的，即惯用语识别。他说其中之一是行归约外积，或者他们称之为表。所以你可以构建一个表并对每一行进行归约，这实际上不会具体化。总之，我在想是否会有某种GPU等效方案，可能对每个元素进行二分查找最终会更高效。但你可以做类似的事情。比如融合查找的结果
with the with the next operation yeah like so i'm trying to think if you did some outer like you could implement dyadic iota technically in terms of like a outer product for for small arrays i i do have that just directly in there and you can fuse that yeah and uh this is just for outer product in general you're saying saying? Yeah, yeah. Okay. Outer product can get fused with other things, because on the GPU, we just tile it out. Right. And we do the operations. So if you've got fusion on your scalar operations, then you can fuse that outer product.
与下一次操作结合，是的，所以我在想如果你做了一些外积，从技术上讲，你可以用小数组的外积来实现二元iota，我确实直接在里面有这个，而且你可以融合它，是的，呃，你是指这只是针对一般的外积吗？是的，是的。好的。外积可以与其他东西融合，因为在GPU上，我们只是将其平铺。对吧。然后我们执行操作。所以如果你在标量操作上有融合，那么你就可以融合那个外积。
Yeah, that's super, super nice, because it's a very common pattern that you blow something up into a table, and then you immediately want to shrink it back down on a row or column basis. Yeah. And then... As long as the memory requirements for that are small enough, then yeah, it makes sense. And sometimes it actually may make more sense than you think. If you have too little data to really saturate the GPU, sometimes it's worth it to do a little extra computation, saturate the GPU a little bit better, and make use of all that computation power, even though you're slightly less asymptotically efficient. Yeah. That's becoming a problem that our GPUs, especially
是的，这非常好，因为这是一种非常常见的模式，即你将某些东西展开成表格，然后立即希望在行或列的基础上将其缩小。是的。而且……只要内存需求足够小，那么是的，这是有意义的。有时它实际上可能比你想象的更有意义。如果你拥有的数据太少，无法真正让 GPU 饱和，有时值得进行一些额外的计算，让 GPU 饱和度更高一点，并利用所有这些计算能力，即使你的渐近效率稍微低一点。是的。这正成为我们的 GPU 面临的一个问题，尤其是
in the latest like Blackwell models, they're getting so big that it's actually very difficult for small problems. I mean, the national labs in America don't have any problem saturating our GPUs, but like for a, you know, a single node, you're just doing something at home. It is actually very hard to put your GPU to full use. And so now there's technologies coming out where they're actually partitioning your GPU virtually into smaller GPUs because
在最新的 Blackwell 模型中，它们变得如此之大，以至于对于小问题来说实际上非常困难。我的意思是，美国的国家实验室在让我们的 GPU 饱和方面没有任何问题，但对于像你自己在家里做点什么的单节点来说，实际上很难充分利用你的 GPU。所以现在出现了一些技术，它们实际上将你的 GPU 虚拟分区成更小的 GPU，因为
then you can descend multiple tasks as if you have a multi-node system. I would take advantage of that if I could. I mean, most of us don't have Blackwell GPUs, so it's not a problem for most of us. I don't even have a Blackwell GPU. I think I've got an Ampere in my work laptop. I think I've only got like three or four. No, that's a joke.
这样你就可以像拥有多节点系统一样分派多个任务。如果可以的话，我会利用这一点。我的意思是，我们大多数人都没有 Blackwell GPU，所以这对我们大多数人来说不是问题。我甚至没有 Blackwell GPU。我想我的工作笔记本电脑里有一个 Ampere。我想我只有三四个。不，那是开玩笑的。
Of course I don't have any. Alright, well we're at the, what time is it? We're at the 30 minute mark. Maybe we'll take a small break here. This is going to be a week for the listener. It's going to be like four minutes for us. And then we're going to talk about Tersity and the pitch that I don't know how to make for why tersity matters.
我当然没有。好吧，我们现在，现在几点了？我们已经到了 30 分钟的节点。也许我们在这里休息一下。对于听众来说，这会是一周的时间。对我们来说大约是四分钟。然后我们将讨论简洁性，以及我不知道该如何推销为什么简洁性很重要的观点。
All this has been the warm up to the... I mean, that was the initial topic. Yeah. All right. We'll be back in a sec. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
所有这些都是……的预热。我的意思是，那是最初的话题。是的。好的。我们马上回来。请务必查看你的播客应用程序或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上的节目说明，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那不是标语。我们的标语是充满信息碎片的混乱。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。